Transcriber: Zeinab Alnayal
المدقّق: Hadeel Manaseer
(تصفيق)
السلام عليكم.
أول شيء، مفهوم الحياة المثالية.
ما هو مفهوم الحياة المثالية؟
إذا سألت جميع الموجودين في الغرفة
"ما هي الحياة المثالية بالنسبة لكم؟"
الغالبية ربما، أو دعنا نقول البعض
سيجيب: منزل، سيارة،
ومن يمتلك منزلاً أو سيارة سيجيب:
بيت أكبر، سيارة أكبر
أشياء أكثر، ماديات أكثر.
هذا السؤال الذي دائمًا
ما نطرحه على أنفسنا،
ونربط حياتنا المثالية بالسعادة؛
"كيف أستطيع الوصول إلى السعادة؟"
ولكن، ما هي السعادة؟
هذا السؤال الذي لطالما
يطرحه الإنسان على نفسه؛
كيف يستطيع الإنسان ملء
الفراغ الداخلي الموجود فيه؟
للأسف، أغلبنا يستخدم نفس الطريقة
نملؤ هذا الفراغ بأشياء
سواء كانت: موضة، ملابس
دائمًا أشياء وأشياء.
نعم!
طبعاً هذا ما يحدث معنا.
أشياء وأشياء. أنا لا أتحدث فقط عن خزانة
الملابس بل عن جميع أجزاء البيت.
هذا ما يحدث.
ولهذا السبب، سأتحدث اليوم
عن مفهوم ربما كان متواجداً منذ الأزل
لكن ما زلت، وما زلنا جميعاً
نُذكِّر أنفسنا به
وهو "التجرّد".
التجرّد.
طبعاً اختياري لترجمة الـ "Minimalism"
أخذ وقتًا طويلًا.
قد تكون الترجمة الفعلية لـ "Minimalism"
هي التخفُّف،
والغالبية يعرفونها بمفهوم التخفُّف.
لكن بالنسبة لي، المعنى الجوهري
لـ "Minimalism" هو:
التجرّد.
من الممكن أن أطلب منك تخفيف الماديات.
حسنًا...
خزانة ملابسي أو حاجياتي
تخلصت من نصفها، وانتهى الموضوع.
لكنّ التجرّد كان بالنسبة لي
معنى وقعه أعمق،
لأنّك لا تتخفف من الماديات فقط...
لا...
أنت تتجرّد من أن تجعل الماديات تملكك.
لا، أنا آخذ الماديات وأسخرّها لما أحتاجه،
لأنّها ليست موجودة لتحدد هدفي، أو سعادتي،
أو حياتي المثالية.
الحياة الفاخرة،
الحياة السعيدة،
جميعنا نطمح دائماً لهذه الأشكال.
أفضل منزل، أفضل سيارة.
قد يكون أغلبنا يتوجه لموضوع
الحياة المثالية في الغِنى،
لكن مثلما قال أحد المشاهير:
"أتمنى لو كان الجميع أغنياء
ليعرفوا أنّها ليست الإجابة."
كثير من الأغنياء توصلوا إلى الهدف
الذي يفكر فيه الغالبية الآن،
لكنّهم اكتشفوا أنّها ليست الإجابة،
ليست هذه السعادة،
ليست هذه الحياة المثالية
التي توقعت أنّها هدفي.
من المؤكد أنّ الإعلام له دور كبير
في هذا الموضوع.
ما يحدث، هو أنّ حياة المشاهير المُجسَّدة،
الموجودة في حياتنا والتي نراها يوميًا،
جسَّدت لي ما أريد الوصول إليه بالتحديد.
الذي حدث هو أنّ دماغي
برمجت على رغبة الوصول لهذه الحياة؛
حياة المشاهير، حياة الرفاهية.
الإعلام هو من أقنعني بهذا الشيء،
سواء كان في الدعايات، أو الحياة،
أو المنازل الموجودة في الدعايات.
اقتنعت بالنظام السائد عن طريق الإعلام.
دعاية واحدة فقط
كافية لتغيير مفهومك الكامل عن هدفك
أو المرحلة القادمة التي تود الوصول إليها.
طبعاً قديمًا، كانت العلامات التجارية
تُصمم فقط للشتاء والصيف.
لا يوجد عندي سوى الصيف والشتاء
للتصميم من أجله،
أو أربع فصول كحد أقصى.
لكن ما يحدث حالياً مع كل الثورات
والأشياء التي حدثت
أصبحوا يصممون لاثنين وخمسين فصلًا.
ما يعنيه ذلك وما يحدث في كل مرة هو كالآتي:
سترى أنّ ما تملكه لا يواكب الموضة،
ويجب أن تشتري الشيء الجديد
الذي يواكب الموضة،
ويجب أن تشتري المزيد من الأشياء.
وستلاحظ أنّك كل أسبوعين أو شهر
ستذهب إلى السوق لشراء شيء جديد.
طبعاً هذه خدعة، حيث أنّهم يُشعرونك
أنّك تريد أن تشتري أكثر، وأكثر، وأكثر.
الجمعة السوداء، دائماً هناك تنزيلات
تصيب الناس بالجنون والرغبة العارمة بالشراء
حتى لو لم يكونوا بحاجة إلى ذلك،
حتى لو كانوا يملكون
تلفازاً في المنزل
لكنّ الذي يحدث هو الحاجة إلى المزيد
لأنّني أرى هذه العروض،
وجميع ذلك في النهاية هو خدعة إعلامية،
لماذا؟
لكي أسوِّق منتجاتي، ولكي أجعل الناس
لا يشعرون بالرضى الكامل بشكل دائم.
طبعا بما أنّني معمارية، ويجب أن أُدخل
الموضوع في تخصصي،
ومن المؤكد أنّ له علاقة بتخصصي.
آه، بحكم عملي، دوماً ما أتلقى الطلب ذاته،
ذات الشيء عندما أصمم المنازل.
آه، أريد صالونات 5×10 أو 20×30،
أريد أن يجلس الجميع في...
حسناً، لا مشكلة لدي،
ولكن ما سيحدث هو عندما تشتري أشياء أكثر
ستحتاج إلى مساحة أكثر.
طبعا هذا منزل، لنتخيله منزلاً سعودياً.
أتوقع أنّ هذا المفهوم موجود
لدى جميع المنازل السعودية؛
في الطابق الأرضي، صالونات
لا تستخدم إلّا مرة في السنة.
حسناً لا تحزنوا، لتكن ثلاث مرات.
الطابق الأرضي دائماّ مهجور رغم أنّه يحوي
أغلى الأشياء وهو الأجمل دائماً،
وهو ما نصادفه في عملنا، حيث يأتي شخص
ويطلب أن تكون غرفة الضيوف على المسبح،
ولكنّك تعيش في غرفة المعيشة،
لمَ لا تجعل غرفة المعيشة على المسبح؟
ففي النهاية، أنت الذي سيعيش في هذا المنزل،
ولكن نحن نختار أن يرانا الناس دائماً
من خلال الماديات التي نملكها.
طبعاً أُجريت دراسات لشقة سكنية،
والحمدلله أنّها لم تكن فيلا
أو منزل في السعودية،
أنّ العائلة تسخدم فقط 40% من المنزل.
طبعاً هذه خريطة توضح أغلب الأماكن
التي تستخدمها العائلة.
ستكون مصيبة لو أُجريت الدراسة على فيلا،
الحمدلله أنّها لم تُجرى على فيلا.
قد يعتقد الغالبية أنّ مفهوم التجرّد
بدأ في أوروبا،
أو بدأ في الدول الآسيوية رغم أنّهم يملكون
اقتصاداً أقوى من اقتصادنا،
ولكنّهم متمسكون تماماً بمفهوم التجرّد.
ولكن في الأصل، بدأ هذا المفهوم من عندنا،
وهذا يسبب الحزن.
أنّه منذ القدم، العرب والمسلمين خاصة،
كانوا دائماً ما يتكلمون عن مفهوم التجرّد.
ولكن للآسف، نسيناه نحن.
طبعاً كانت هناك إحدى المشاريع
التي تُدعى Life Edited
أه، ابتدأوا بنشر موضوع التجرّد،
وبدأ الناس بمحاربتهم،
برأيهم أنّ المساحة الصغيرة التي يقصدونها
ستؤدي إلى ظهور مشاكل اجتماعية،
حيث لن يتمكن الشخص من استقبال مجموعة كبيرة
في هذا البيت الصغير الذي يقصدونه.
وكان الرد من نفس المنظمة
أنّه يمكن تحويل مساحة غرفة المعيشة
إلى غرفة طعام عند استقبال الأصدقاء.
لماذا نعاني دائماً من مشكلة تخصيص
غرفة طعام الضيوف للضيوف فقط؟
يمكن استخدامها لعدّة أمور.
لماذا نحدد المساحات دوماً
بطريقة لا تمكننا من استخدامها؟
لماذا لدينا هدر؟
طبعاً الغرفة التي على يمين الصورة
هي دون طاولة الطعام،
والتي على اليسار تحوي طاولة طعام.
جميعها في مساحة واحدة،
تمكنوا من استخدامها ثلاث استخدامات:
مكتب، غرفة طعام للتجمع، وغرفة معيشة.
كان هذا بالنسبة لهم نجاح ساحق،
حيث أنّهم كانوا قادرين على فعل ذلك.
أنا لا أعني أنّ علينا التجرّد
وأن نكون متطرفين في ذلك
ونكتفي باستعمال 33 قطعة مثل بعض الناس
الذين وصلوا إلى تلك المرحلة.
أنا لا أقول أنّه عليك التخلّص
من جميع أغراضك، و...
ففي النهاية، لكل شيء حد معين،
ولكن كمفهوم نريد أن يتبناه المجتمع،
يجب أن نبدأ من البداية؛
على الأقل، قبل أن أشتري شيئاً
أو قبل أن أمتلك شيء،
يجب أن أسأل نفسي: هل أحتاجه فعلاً؟
ما هي نسبة احتياجي إلى هذا الشيء؟
قبل أن أبني منزلي، يجب أن أفكر،
هل سأستخدم كل غرفة منه؟
أم هي موجودة لكي لا أستخدمها؟
ما أريد إيصاله فقط
أنّه قبل أن تشتري أو تملك أي شيء
فكر أولاً بالسبب الذي يدفعك
لشراء هذا الشيء.
لا تدع الماديات تملكك، عليك أنت امتلاكها
وتسخيرها للشيء الذي تريده.
وشكراً.
(تصفيق)